this investigation has uncovered the  most shocking and harrowing child  observance I have ever seen there is no  doubt in my mind that Ian Watkins has  exploited a celebrity status in order to  abused young children today's outcome  ensures that three people responsible to  be brought to justice  the safeguarding of children has been a  primary objective for this investigation  and the open and the outcome of this  investigation has been achieved through  a multi-agency approach at an  international level to very young  children have been removed from this  abuse and given a future that would  otherwise have been denied them